a la audiencia transcurrió en medio de
alta expectativa en el país se vio Pedro
Castillo
débil
tratarmudeando no quiso hablar mucho con
el juez en esta audiencia la fiscalía
peruana pidió siete días de detención
preliminar contra el ex gobernante
porque
señala que cometió el fragante delito de
vulnerar el orden constitucional y al
pedir a las fuerzas armadas que
respalden sus disolución del Congreso
esto constituye los delitos de rebelión
y conspiración la fiscalía también
señala que Pedro Castillo tuvo las
intenciones de Establecer un asilo
político y para eso visitó la embajada
de México en Lima Y eso constituye un
alto peligro de fuga por su parte la
defensa del ex mandatario ha rechazado
los cargos y ha señalado que no puede
hablarse de delitos de rebelión y porque
según la Constitución peruana para que
eso exista se requiere un alzamiento de
armas y tal como lo señala la defensa de
Castillo el ex gobernante no se alzó en
armas tampoco usó la violencia y no puso
en peligro la estabilidad del parlamento
peruano el tribunal luego de oír los
alegatos tanto de la fiscalía como de la
defensa señaló que notificará su
veredicto en las partes en los próximos
días
Francisco Y qué le espera ahora al ex
mandatario
Pedro Castillo se encuentra vulnerable
en estos momentos no tiene poder
carece de inmunidad y le queda muy pocos
amigos y aliados él es gobernante
arrastra seis acusaciones en la fiscalía
por presunta corrupción Y estos últimos
cargos de rebelión y conspiración
podrían llevarlo a prisión si es
declarado culpable a cumplir una pena
privativa de la libertad que va Entre 10
a 20 años pero eso no es todo la
fiscalía también está alistando medidas
para hacer un pedido a la corte de
impedimento de salida del país porque
señala que existe el peligro de fuga del
ex gobernante y también se prepara un
nuevo pedido de atención esta vez sería
una prisión preventiva que podría ser de
18 a 36 meses según me han dicho algunos
juristas así las cosas todas indicar que
Pedro Castillo podría pasar una larga
temporada en el penal de barbadío es una
cárcel que es policial donde justamente
ahí purga condena el presidente el
expresidente Alberto fujimori Quien
cumple 25 años de cárcel